hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to human shop now this game
is uh Wow
I don't exactly know I played a few
levels of it it was suggested by you
guys so thank you for the suggestion but
someone said that it was bloody terrible
horrifying and all of the above so
basically you hope we have to do is
squish little Yumi's and eat their
delicious flesh aha oh boy who wouldn't
want to do that but it's like a physics
based game and I imagine that this is
kind of like a app type game one of
those that go on the newfangled phony
devices blab oh god is so sad that you
just want to live Who am I why I doing
this
what is this what am i clicking oh oh
okay
fake friends I wonder if there's like
some horrible like actual message to be
said about this so okay oh no oh no oh
no oh god it's so horrible why am I
playing this oh man it's so mean we
doing this oh well let's keep going
hatred yeah
oh god it's those oh I mean at that
point it's their fault they were
standing underneath the blocks they
could have seen obviously that something
was awry when they wandered underneath a
block held up by a tiny to be the string
when random slices are going through the
entire sky rivalry I don't know what
that means
hey ah oh okay I get it okay so I need
to time this so that they they basically
will yeah Archy poop well I guess maybe
yes haha I liked how I did a 180 from
being like this is horrible de yes I
squished the UMI's Oh God uh
that's what you get for listening to
music that's one iyi win-win-win-win-win
a little that's why whenever I Drive my
car I listen to air idles there is some
deeper meaning to this there's some
avant-garde habitat there too huh
there's some avant-garde [ __ ] going on
here and I don't like it
Oh God ah wait oh well this guy panic I
know what this is this guy's gonna panic
he's gonna inform them yeah that's the
stuff oh well he just walked into it and
died was he sucked under by the power of
the cube this is like cube the movie
plane I don't know what I'm blaming all
right then little dude is here oh it's
like physics oh it's so physical okay so
I got this I know what do ah it's the
world's worst office ball clacker that
kills you I guess so if I run run a [ __ ]
and run run run huh yes oh they were
crushed by the weights of society's
expectations I shouldn't read so much
into this the premise of it was that
you're just trying to make burgers I
mean how bad could that be I guess it's
pretty bad
whoops sorry oh gosh not so sorry
accidents you know it's just that bad
huh Oh
huh damn it hang on a second these are
getting hard okay so I think I need to
get this guy to his dismay [ __ ]
ah that's what I need to do I need to
push this guy to where he's good ah [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] dude ah [ __ ]
okay so I need to wash it ha ha ha ha ha
ha ha run run
oh no oh he was in such blissful
ignorance how could you do that to a man
how could you do that
oh no I know yeah ah yeah ah ha ha ha I
like I really don't have issues I want
to put that out there right there I
don't have issues I think I'm ok about
this hypocrisy bang yes it's a so
vicious with the s and bloody horrible
violence at every turn anything shall
not run away from me ha ha wait I mean
let me see how many levels I have oh I'm
almost done
let me give you the premise first like
halfway through in big city you are just
a blind meat chop sometimes in buns with
sesame seeds and as literally all there
is so then a fatal is Bosh oh he died
from the fall is that still gonna get
delicious human meat for my meat buns I
need a lot of meat buns ok so oh no oh
he's smart oh he has glasses which means
he am smart ha ha ha
ok I got this
what's to be envious your delicious meat
hook expectation there is seriously some
deeper meaning to all this and I'm not
getting it because I can't see through
the haze of bloodlust all I want to do
is eat these horrible horrible all not
horrible in my mind I'm going so insane
that I think these humans are now
horrible I'm looking from the
perspective of a meat burner and a meat
merchants murder murder murder I'm a
murderer I'm a burger murderer
maybe so they're crushed by the weight
of life's expectations Oh God uh-huh
okay yeah yeah ah goddamn it
pip haw one's getting away huh
ah I know what to do whoop hey I've got
you now oh I've got to now oh I've got
ya okay
oh yeah I did he ran right into it he
was trying to you know exceed his
expectations and that didn't work out
too well for him though it did that Noah
did natch he didnêt there's no idea what
to do with his life
Harish Oh confused huh okay Oh ah
shelter oh okay
so oh you so stupid I got you didn't
even need the one on the top oh I am I
am what I am dead ah yes
okay I guess I won human Jeff that was
interesting a quick little thing not too
bad so I hope they're actually make more
levels of this because the concept is
not foreign the concept is definitely
not foreign but the execution is what
makes it interesting like the idea that
like this weird world where humans are
meat and you have to squish him like
that's different it makes more like
engaging it makes me want to play more
that's what makes it interesting game in
terms of everything else that's been
made in the same genre and I love the
stylistic gray grayscale and yet the
blood is red like that's a nice touch to
it
I turned into a horrible murdering made
a actor at the end of this video but
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
without a baby what is this cutie oh
come on